and joining us that one month from today
we will be in the middle of what appears
to be Opening Day weekend for the 2020
Major League Baseball season that the
last time I spoke to this guy looked
like it would never happen on this green
earth but it did happen
apparently get the latest right now for
man who's been all over from the
athletic event relic joining us back
here in the show how are you sir
rich we made it have we we're sure well
the next step here and this could happen
likely today is they have to finalize
the schedule the union has to basically
sign off on that I'm told that that is
likely an occurrence today so they are
making still steady progress and then
there's this interesting possibility
that we could still maybe end up with an
expanded postseason if the league made
an offer to the union that the union
liked and there's no indication that
that's happened yet but that possibility
still does exist well I want to put a
pin in that because that takes us a
little bit a field of of the issue that
the seasons gonna start what to make of
all the reports that we're gonna hear
more and more of we heard it already
about the Texas Rangers we heard it
about the Philadelphia Phillies the
Colorado Rockies having three players
including our friend Charlie Blackmon
testing positive for coronavirus the
Blue Jays coming in from Canada have
tested for coronavirus I'm assuming all
30 teams are gonna have some member of
their crew that's gonna be facilitating
these games or the players themselves
testing positive for coronavirus how
does the league handle all this stuff
well this is why they went from a 67
page document outlining the protocols
for this season to a 101 page document
and the question of what do they do if
they have a mass outbreak on a given
team there really isn't a single answer
it in every situation here they're going
to have replacements available and so
you're hoping that if guys do come down
with it and they will as you're right
there's no way when you have this many
people it's just a numbers game that
you're not gonna have people who get
covet 19 you have to have alternatives
lined up and the questionable what do
you do if a whole team gets it that's
still a good question you know they are
not intending to shut down unless they
have to but that that worst-case
scenario I think still looms in the back
of people's minds well cuz it's not just
look the players we haven't heard about
any hospitalizations or any serious
illness but there are remember and every
leagues gonna have to deal with this the
NBA even Greg Popovich is a 70 year old
man there are so many members of
coaching staffs who are beyond
vulnerable that if coronavirus is there
and they catch it this is a whole
different story and the question is is
is anybody opting out are you hearing
any of that when does this conversation
take place Evan in a way it's already
taking place every team doctor has to
put together a list in the organization
not just players of people who are
considered high-risk and nobody is gonna
be forced to be out there the problem is
from an employee standpoint the players
are covered by the Union everyone else
if they choose not to go there basically
at the mercy of the club as to whether
they are paid and that's going to likely
be a team by team and maybe even simply
case by case decision whether a team is
feeling generous about a guy's position
but this is why they've developed these
different protocols if you're high risk
you have a certain set of testing
procedures if you're not high risk
they've tried try being the key word to
map all this out but it's got to be a
living breathing document there's no way
to really preemptively figure all this
out Evans relic of the athletic gear on
the Rich Eisen show okay so have have
the protocols been agreed to is that all
set
yes they they've reached an agreement on
this 101 page protocols they've got a
still set the schedule officially as I
said but that was the endgame a couple
days ago here once the league announced
we're going to implement we're gonna do
this sixty game season the thing that
took about basically a day at that point
was getting the health protocols
finalized and they had been close on
that for some time it didn't take a
massive amount of heavy lifting because
they every cent revisions back the Union
had to the leave but yeah the health
protocols are agreed to and there's
going to be this joint committee between
the league in the Union where if there
are any disputes for example whether a
guy is indeed classified as high risk
they have a way to sort that stuff out
already devised internally so let's
let's get into whether players are gonna
maybe not show up because the manner in
which this was implemented is there any
any issue with that or is the bad blood
that was boiling over is that finally
now at a simmer or if we turn the heat
off on that oh no the bad blood is
absolutely still gonna be there but it's
gonna come down really to questions of
money because if you are not high risk
and you sit out you're at the mercy of
the club and and those likelihood that a
club is going to say yeah even though
you're not high risk we're gonna pay you
is very small the the question is guys
who live with somebody who's high risk
so a player who has a pregnant wife or a
young child maybe young child who's
immunocompromised and they choose to sit
out the Union pushed very hard to have
it in the agreement in the health
protocols if those people could sit out
and still receive service time or even
pay they didn't get that in the
agreement so if you're somebody who's
living with someone high risk and you
are not yourself high risk you're the
choice to make and there's some hope
that teams will be accommodating there's
some wiggle room to MLD has a paternity
list and they'll be has a restricted
list where guys could go so there's some
flex
ability there but there's no guarantee
for those people so if anybody's on a
bubble I would think it's them it's not
the high risk individuals because
they're kind of taken care of it's those
who live with somebody who's high risk
if they are not themselves high risk
having Drella the athletic here on the
Rich Eisen show so let's talk about what
this schedule is are everybody's playing
in their home stadiums that is that how
it's gonna work and then I guess I've
got a two-part question there you could
start if you will about the Blue Jays
are they gonna have a bubble because I
can definitely see no contact no flying
into Canada and vice versa that the Blue
Jays are just gonna have to come into
the United States and stay for the
duration from when July first hits all
the way through to how long they last in
the in the season so as of yesterday
this is per information that the Union
gave two player agents the Blue Jays
have asked their government Canadian
government local government whoever that
might end up beating for permission to
play in Toronto and they're supposed to
hear back today maybe the next couple
days an end of the week type of thing if
they get approval on that they're gonna
ask to play spring training in Toronto
and that would probably take another
five or so days to get that approval if
they don't get that approval they'll
probably go to the meeting which is
where they train normally down in
Florida and then the alternate training
site and this part actually as a native
New York State person yes they could end
up in Buffalo they could end up playing
their spring training in Buffalo spring
training part two so that's kind of neat
I think and that's where their triple-a
team is normally that's the the stadium
that Billy Crystal used to shoot 61
right it's a beautiful old school
Stadium in Buffalo New York if I'm not
mistaken so that's so that's where they
would that's where they would camp out
and that's where they would have their
their games huh and and you know what I
mean that would make sense in terms of
the Pirates visiting the phillies
visiting the Yankees visiting the Red
Sox visiting the Mets visiting I mean
that is a geographically sound location
one would think right for them to play
there
the East teams in this schedule are all
at something of an advantage because
they don't have to change time zones
you're playing only your division your
normal division within your league and
your division in the other league so at
least plays Anneliese
and a least the West teams are really
kind of screwed in this regard because
they're gonna have to traverse three
different time zones they're a central
mountain and west coast so it would make
sense to have the Blue Jays in Buffalo
if you needed to but I don't wanna make
that a likelihood at this point because
they're trying to do everything they can
to stay in Toronto right so okay so the
schedule would be what again it national
and American mixed together it's all
just it's all one big geographical happy
family is that the way it would work
yeah East plays East and both leagues
central play Central West plays West and
every team's gonna play ten games
against its normal division so a elite
teams were playing ten games against
every other AL East team so that ends up
being 40 games and then the other twenty
games are playing against the East in
the other League the National League if
you're in Al each team and most of these
series are going to be three game and
two game series okay and then any
doubleheaders know it's looking unlikely
that there will be schedule
doubleheaders it doesn't mean that we
won't end up having them because
realistically there's not going to be a
lot of office you I think I think it's
60 games in 66 days is what they're
attempting to pull off at this point I
just don't have that number in front of
me but basically if you have a rainout
or you have to reschedule something
particularly with all these teams likely
to remain something close to contention
you're not gonna have a ton of teams
fall out of it so you might need to get
every game played it's totally possible
at some point you end up with a
doubleheader okay
now let's get into EV and relic of the
athletic year and the Rich Eisen show
let's now unpin what we discussed
earlier on you talked about expanded
playoff still a possibility is the is
the universal D H in this mix
for this year the universal DHS already
agreed to and that's because of Health
that's for the feeling that you're going
to keep pitchers in better shape and you
just don't want a guy going down because
you left second base awkwardly you're
gonna have limited rosters you're not
gonna have in all likelihood you're not
gonna have a full minor-league schedule
going on in the background so just for
health reasons this year you're gonna
have the D H in both leagues if they had
had an agreement on a new deal that
would have brought the d h for next year
as well but you do still have the d h
inside of this year well and in terms of
that to Evan with the expanded playoffs
you saw what Trevor Bauer had to say
essentially doing a little bit of a heel
turn on on his Union and it kind of
makes sense is the fact that okay
you-you-you wanted to keep the ability
to file a grievance in your back pocket
that is what definitely keeps the
ownership and management on their heels
but when management it put on the table
so many different pieces of candy I
guess that would have actually led to
more money being in the pocket of the
players right now don't you think that
that would actually benefit so is that
why we're hearing that or you mentioned
that the expanded playoffs could be
still on the table for this year so
you're right that the league did dangle
extra candy for the players and the
calculation most of the players made
here is that yes there was a little bit
more candy that we could have had but in
in exchange for that we would have had
to give the league back so much more
candy that it wasn't a fair deal it
doesn't mean that we as players would
not have been a slightly better position
for 2020 had we taken that deal
objectively they would have been there
was a little bit more money available
for them inside this year it's that in
return for that they would have had to
give back things that they simply valued
to be a lot higher and look in a way
you can say the gamble worked because
they're getting a 60 game season which
is exactly the number that the league
had made in its last offer and it's not
like they're getting fewer games here
and as it goes to the expanded
postseason that's what the league wanted
there's more money attached to it for
the league if they can have the expanded
postseason if the league now turns
around and says hey we will give you
let's say instead of the twenty five
million dollars that was discussed in
the last offer we'll give you I don't
know 50 or some number that makes the
players go okay that's enough then yeah
we could still have the expanded
postseason in 2020 okay Evans relic here
on the Rich Eisen show what am I not
asking this is really gonna happen I
don't I I don't I don't need to be
trifled with anymore
quite honestly Evan what am I not asking
what's play with your emotions anymore
which I don't think the question has
always been the same going back months
here it was really never except maybe in
the last couple weeks it was really
never are they gonna start this season
it's are they gonna finish and the
problem is you don't have that answer I
don't have that answer none of them have
that answer and I wouldn't say I'm
completely optimistic about it the the
chance that we actually get through all
this and they don't have to shut down
again that we get through a whole
postseason but it seems like most people
feel like it's worth trying and then
there's of course some people who think
baseball shouldn't even be back that
it's not safe enough but I think the
general consensus is it's worth the
attempt and thankfully they're able to
make the attempt without being halted by
money rather than the help right so cuz
because if if they have to stop down
because of health then everybody could
sit here and say we tried and every
other league is trying I mean every
other league is going every other league
is gonna try and figure out how to deal
with coronavirus cases popping up that
that's expected to pop up and hoping
that therapeutics catch up and all that
stuff my buddy Keith Olbermann tweeted
out he also texted this to me yesterday
on my birthday no less sorry belated
thank you sir training camp opens
50 percent season opens 25% series
concludes 0% what do you think about
that I don't think it's quite that low
honestly but it goes back to what we
were discussing earlier they they can
handle a few guys testing positive
because you can test positive and be
asymptomatic or have already recovered
it you know the testing positive itself
is not necessarily the most damaging not
necessarily the problem is what if you
have a mass outbreak to the point that
you're really kind of impacting the
entire character of a team and you hope
that you never get to that point and
maybe it is statistically unlikely that
in fact you would have an outbreak quite
that large but you still have to
consider that worst case scenario what
are you gonna have in 25 replacement
players 26 because that's what the
roster will end up being this year you
start out with 30 then you go to 28 then
you go to 26 yeah you can't reasonably
replace an entire team and say yeah that
was uh that was the Phillies in 2020
when they look nothing like what you
would expect them to be so in the end it
could end up in kind of imputing the
competitive component of this right if a
team looks nothing like it was supposed
to well what do you make of the 2020
season but this is all the worst-case
scenario okay I'm gonna ask you baseball
question Evan how about that how about
this before I let you go wonderful how
about this no epidemiology no no labor
law required here just baseball
knowledge how about this an actual
baseball question the 60 games schedule
give me a team not the blueblood okay
not though we got 200 million dollars in
the bank you know for our for our low
and don't give a crap about the luxury
you mean no Red Sox to pal okay
by the way Liverpool's doing great trust
me all right
Werner and Henry are not knocking on the
door like like it's Trading Places out
there okay so give me the name of a team
that we're not talking about that could
debt that that a 60 game schedule could
absolutely let them catch fire and they
a shot to win a World Series this year
Evan I'm gonna rip off my colleague at
the athletic Jason Starkey award in his
piece about a day ago he notices the
twins and the Indians are gonna play
just four teams that had a winning
record last year and the hardest
schedules are gonna go to the Marlins
Orioles and Blue Jays because they're
gonna play seven teams they had records
of 500 or better so look to general
principles specific teams aside is that
if you're a mediocre team you've got a
much better chance now because usually
in a 162 game slate you get exposed you
can have a good first half of the season
how many times have we seen somebody at
the all-star break
who's kind of in it you think it's a
wild-card team that they totally fade
out in the second half well you have a
second half now you don't even have a
full first half so it's gonna have teams
that probably shouldn't be there on
their merit but nonetheless they're
gonna be there right
okay what about the Padres I'm only
given a wet kiss to all those Padre fans
I pissed off last week because I use
them basically as a foil what about them
what about them what give me a minute
give me an NL team we got one well you
know they were under the belief that
they would end up contending this year
anyway even in a 162 game season this is
why they unveiled their new jerseys this
year it was supposed to be kind of this
culmination of the franchise rebuild the
prospects had arrived they've already
signed Machado and Hosmer I think they
said in that category of wear if you
were to look at it in a hundred sixty
two game season they're probably not the
best team in that division
but in this setting I will be the NL
Central is another team I saw somebody
on another division on Twitter yesterday
I can't remember what report it was but
I think it was nips projections or one
of these fancy statistical projections
yes that whole division looks like it's
going to be three games at the part so
you're gonna have wild races in every
division won't this be great I mean just
if the virus will actually cooperate
that that that the heavens can open and
we can actually finish this damn thing
that would be amazing what about
analytics normally you need a big sample
size it's going to be a smaller sample
size now you're putting somebody on
second base to start the
and thinning because you don't want
something going nineteen innings when
there you got only got sixty six days
for you know sixty games and then the
rosters who knows what's gonna happen
there I mean we're gonna see actual gut
feel more than ever before do you think
yeah are you gonna throw a lot of this
stuff out the windy weather whether it's
insurance to analytics whether it's an
adherence to purity of the sport with
the D H and the NL and everything that
they're changing for this year including
that extra inning rule with the runner
on second base you know you don't have
that option anymore it managers can
still I'm sure try to manage by the book
is given to them by their front office's
but when every game is so magnified now
usually in in the regular season of 162
games the moments where the book gets
thrown out the window anyway is highest
intensity you know are you gonna go by
your numbers you're gonna go by your
feel for what that guy looks like at the
plate today
what he's been doing lately the body
language all that when you're in a
narrow pennant race here which is what
the season really is gonna be I do think
you'll see guys managing by the book but
less by the book well maybe we could use
social distancing mandates to get rid of
the shift what do you think about that
you got to spread it out can't be can't
beat you can't be too close everybody's
got to be on their side of second base
damnit I hate that shift man yes I'm
sorry I just used the pandemic to make
my case to get rid of shift I understand
you think it's too soon I'm sorry I hate
the shift I'm sorry I haven't I didn't
mean to drag you down with me
you know I just remember the first time
the place would be the first thing Rob
Manfred said publicly as a commissioner
was that he was thinking about banning
the ship and he got roastin sure didn't
work people could not believe it but you
know what
I did an interview with him in early
October last year as the playoffs are
starting we're talking about these
higher-level issues in the game and he
made a great point that all these genes
their only goal is to win one more game
and it impacts the entertainment value
of the sport and he knows his office
needs to be certainly one of them I
think along with the Union thinking
about
is that actually good for the sport yeah
it's great that the GM's want to win one
more game but is it fun to watch and
give give a little bit of credit here
it's kind of an auxilary bonus you're
gonna get a different looking product
this year and that in itself might be
more fun to watch I hope so man you know
what I mean
IIIi yes I hear you you know my buddy DP
and again we're on Dan Patrick radio
everyday on Sirius XM 211
he points out everybody wants to throw
98 99 100 and then there's only one way
that anybody tries to hit that with a
launch angle and that's it and that's
that's how he wind up with strikeouts
walks or home runs for a majority of
at-bats or at least a growing plurality
of at-bats and it's made it very
difficult to watch but I'm just glad to
have something to watch and it appears
like it's gonna happen and then maybe
just maybe this will be more of a
laboratory on gut and feel that we've
seen in quite some time maybe we get
that Evan that would be great I'm aa
homogeneous baseball isn't fun or at
least not as fun as it could be I would
be interested to see a team that's all
speed and defense with a lineup 1 to 9
of 40 and 30 base stealers 40 40 a year
30 year type of guys versus a power
hitting team and it when everybody looks
the same and to your point about
pitching if everybody's throwing 99 the
excitement of seeing 99 just disappears
and it's all about optimization and
efficiency and blah blah blah corporate
culture that's seeping into baseball and
it goes back to entertainment how do you
want to be entertained I want to see a
guy swipe second base occasion
Evan thanks the call again great stuff
and look for my call again
thanks again appreciate it thanks rich
you got a avid relic of the athletic
joining me here on the Richardson show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here